everybody's turned against me in my
house just because I'm trying to be
echo-friendly here's Sunny hustin
explaining that her family doesn't like
her there is a scond doll in the host
household another one another one y'all
a scandal fil we are a scandal family
because We R by committee which we need
to stop doing I ordered an artificial
gold tree this year ooh and it's
fabulous how trumpish I was just going
to say gold and my daughter that sounds
very trumpy you have a picture is it I
do have a picture I don't know we can
show it but I said palom said we can't
show it palom is like yay and Gabriel
was like that is not good for the
environment and I said yes it is it's
better for the environment and he's like
it's horrible then my husband was like
what is that and so everybody's turned
against me in my house just because I'm
trying to be echo-friendly and then I
just read Echo and then I read about the
tree that you just bought I just want to
put your dog G Gabriel was right real
trees help fight climate change my kid
nobody likes you lady uh she's also
trying to be echo-friendly I think she
means eco-friendly unless she's being
friendly in a k echo echo that's an echo
echo echo echo echo
[Music]
ecological like
okay